donc on retrouve aussi un monde dont
vous ne devez pas ignorer grand chose
mais voilà le japon le japon moderne qui
va tout alors s'opposer au japon
classique voyez que c'est une nouvelle
extrêmement animée avec des buildings de
karachi 18 étages et c'est
extraordinaire il arrive à résister aux
tremblements de terre le même dire que
ce sont les seuls qui aient résisté au
tremblement de terre en 21 mais j'aurais
construction très solide ici très sale
et et du ciment armé et 7,7 foule qu'il
y à deux voitures de piétons on se
demande comment il n'y a pas davantage
textile mais est-ce que c'est toute la
journée cette intensité ça veut dire que
c'est toute la joie et même je dirais
presque que c'est toute la nuit car le
japonais et noctambule il avait
l'habitude de vivre la nuit il aime la
lumière les communautaires les neg le
testing
nous arrivons faste une gare ou une
police très sévère après c'est vers le
policier japonais ne plaisante pas les
contrats dans son club aussi bien sur
les piétons que sur les voitures wii
voit qu'il ya un mélange détient alors
vous voyez ce mélange extraordinaire de
ce bon s'échiner tourist et de cette
femme en costume national zorn voir
beaucoup ou tout ce qui existe sans gêne
sans étonnement syfy coupe
l'événement au vol businessman
personnage gentil
sait jamais si c'est une ombrelle ou
imparable la face et c'est les deux oui
je dois dire qu'il pleut énormément
écran à six mis à pleuvoir ce sont de
véritables kata et c'est dur les joueurs
de sourds mon dieu mais l'envoie
remarqué quelque chose ces femmes
étaient sans détailler en chaussettes
blanches jamais vous devez guînes ma
culture de boue sur la chaussée je ne
sais pas cette année je ne sais pas
comment ils sont toujours des choix cet
impeccable comme ça marche ça marche
dans leur socle et protège peut-être non
et voilà quelque chose qui est
infiniment japonais ce sont les
lanternes et nous allons guinéen
restants qu'est ce qui est écrit
c'est le menu c'est le menu à
landerrouat repose à la maison propose
et vous allez voir les plats sont
exposés avec leurs prix à chaque année
par surprise concernant ya une carte qui
est affiché à l'esprit quand on entre on
sait d'avancé ce que l'on vaut pour
manger on le voit et on sait en plus que
le sras ouvrir payer avant de sortir ces
formations des gâteaux tout ça ce sont
des gâteaux à base de farine de soya
tout tout sauf un à peu près tout ça
après tout même où ça toujours vous
sanwi de purée de marrons un peu épais
un peu épais et alors avec des mélanges
de fourni c'est la violence et de la
crème ah ça c'est la crème ça c'est de
la graine de la glace où ils sont
friands de glace il ya des fortunes à
faire pour les glaciers pas le ice cream
américaine non ce sont des glaces comme
comme les notes plutôt comme les glaces
italiennes voilà les gâteaux alors avec
une variété ce sont des oeuvres d'art
d'ailleurs là bas la pâtisserie et même
la présentation des plats de la
nourriture ordinaire et il ya un art
culinaire
sens de de figuratif ça n'a rien
d'abstrait
sont parce que les concurrents
il ya ulcos l'envié vous ses prêches
bien et ses pommes son coloris et il ya
des dessins des dessins en roulement et
les normands comme partout sont
gourmands et viennent rêver devant les
gâteaux qui se font alors là c'est une
des choses les plus amusantes pour cinq
scènes au goût donne une petite
épuisette formé d'une feuille de papier
à ces trajets tendue sur un cercle de
bande alors avec ça on va ficher des
poissons en droit à pêcher les poissons
et vous ce sont deux genres de
combattants comme quoi sourire il faut
s'en convaincre alors ils sont des
petits sont une vivacité prodigieuse
longue liste et puis c'est en dessous et
empêche de les ramener brillant les
garde naturellement ceux qui ont les on
les garde et on a le droit de pêcher
jusqu'à ce que les plus nets soit dix
chats
boulot là des lichens et à la fin on
redonnera du poleman
alors commence une autre séquence - quoi
ça correspond à peu près à 40 centimes
le poisson
annoncé
lundi bayer en as les fesses à passer à
des fractures
on est ravi de les frapper il abat des
marchands de poissons comme il ya ici
des bistrots c'est beaucoup au départ
sans cela ici et beaucoup
alors la pêche des têtards gens même les
bottes
des pêches des détails vont les aimer
chez eux voilà des p'tits poulbots
exactement renée savait sauf les yeux
[ __ ] la france charles lefrançois
différencie guère ben bongo ce moment
par contre les petits samouraïs mais ce
n'est pas un déguisement et ses pouces
mais elle est charmante
les joueurs de la fête des enfants c'est
un régal de les voir tous les voilà le
grand père grand père horizons aux
leçons être grand-père les japonais ils
sont délicieux tombant faiblesse devant
les petits enfants
et oui on a toujours raison
et sa mission et bien c'est le type du
lieu japonais qui a connu l'ancien
régime et qui s'est très bien adapté aux
nouveaux quand il rentrera chez lui dans
les brassages à cathy se mettre en
kimono il s'installera je pense que
quelques cérémonies du thé que le poison
traces ont été joués et son épouse
viendra à genoux sur les nattes et le
feu sur le navire à bon soir seigneur
est très très agréable qu un homme du
confondues en vie dans ce classement
font-ils les biens 7 ce sont des
teinturiers avant de ces le peloton afin
qu'il a été influent mais sur du bois la
gravure sur moi il est impliqué ensuite
par mordançage les couleurs sont fixés
durant les lava et brando et vous allez
les voir ont été séchés reçu en grandes
grappes raid c'est quelque chose
d'indécent bière et des grands drapeaux
les crocs drapeau de l'onu ne sont rien
à côté punk cela résonnait voir sur ces
petites couleurs à deux tours vertes
années passent à
cette place
mais c'est le coton la soie ne sait plus
fragile sur moi
j'ai cessé les kimonos les kimonos les
ceintures et puis alors le kimono
dessous surtout sur la paix la boucane
car dix plus belles choses vous veniez
vous ce mec dessous après souvent
remporté en kimono surtout pour les
hommes un kimono brun très sobre sous
des formes extrêmes aux postures à tout
moment voilà la question que vous savez
ce sens dit les actrices dg os il faut
dire on pouvait les prendre pareille aux
courtisanes de l'ancien ni graisse ah
oui j'ai femme lettrée cultiver le la
femme légitime reste à la maison et
champion de la maison des enfants
et puis la distraction de l'homme est
une distraction intellectuelle une
section de l'oeil et de lait de nuit
parce que ce sont des chanteuses et
confiés à ces femmes
mais très cher pour une soif vais vous
donner des chiffres assez constant de
facilement dix mille francs pour une
soirée oui je ne devrais pas vous
demander de plus
ce sont des lutteurs des mais ce sont
des lutteurs poids léger car
grands lutteurs chaos qui arrive à 235
kg qui sont généralement très aisé
monroe est particulièrement bas autriche
qui transmet à lâcher le poids joue de
quoi jouer et ben c'est là une cérémonie
c'est un taureau tout simplement qui a
des fleurs de glycine sur le front et
ses folles greetings vous le dire ne
sont pas de vraies fleurs sont des
fleurs en celluloïd oh mon dieu en
plastique et alors il est mené par des
écuyers dans ses idées étudiées sont en
blanc voilà un samouraï ou plutôt aider
nos abeilles nous salir h à niort c'est
en quel honneur tout ça en l'honneur de
la fête des glycines il ya à peu près
150 fait part en
a bien auguré vous non c'était des
chrysanthèmes de ce que les
chrysanthèmes et la fleur impérial
celtique ou une fois le kikuyu yamato le
chrysanthème du revenant preuve alors
les en blanc ce sont les étudier ce
qu'ils sentent à cheval et ce sont des
lignes au seigneur des seigneurs et puis
ce qu'on appela soir enfants enfoncé
sont en verre ou en rouge ce sont des
étudiants ou des soldats dd non pas le
champagne ce officiers et se situe à
quel moment de l'ess l'année la fête du
glycines en avril et la fête des
chrysanthèmes en automne entre-temps il
ya beaucoup de fans qui avaient fait
qu'ils allaient faire des fleurs de
pêcher du fleuve
beaucoup dignité
costumes et alors là se sent aimé les
prêtresses
des temples des temple shinto fait et
toujours mais ne croyait pas que ce soit
des folklores ni des reconstitutions
comme le big bang willy a en belgique
vraiment on relit auront lieu les 30
anciens ce ne sont pas des déguisements
pour un moment en garde tous ses
costumes là et on les remet chaque fois
que l'occasion se présentait voilà
maintenant nous sommes probablement au
théâtre kabuki et voilà un acteur
cette espèce écharpe qu'ils avaient été
eux était brune ses tresses et moins
harmonieux ont connu que chaque geste a
une signification tout le monde connaît
par coeur la pièce tout le monde connaît
la signification des ges et tout bon il
revient il ya six pour le cinquième
vague la même surprise le même
contentement oui c'est plutôt
l'interprétation et la gare charny
plutôt bon et alors avec une subtilité
n'est ce pas un mouvement de lèvres un
oeil qui se ferme ces choristes et l
artiste ou tel autre and roll inova
robin
c'est extraordinaire ce jeu patience en
fait autant pour spectateurs que pour
l'acteur l envoyer ses beaux costumes
anciens sont et costumes à peu près
d'une 14ème 15ème siècle il n'en qu'il
se joue au ralenti ce que je vois
peut-être a menti au ralenti
une signification certainement y allant
prendre un stand à l'évent 2 passes dans
la salle et enfin non pas de chocolat
l'heure s'il souffre mais offre des
sandwiches ou bien des sacs de
cacahuètes oui et ce n'est pas lassant
pour un nouveau camp écoutez ça dure une
une pièce dure deux ou trois jours alors
on revient le lendemain et même le
surlendemain et combien d'exposants des
masques lewis et bien on revient pour
buzzer trois heures quatre heures sur
vingt quatre heures c'est bon c'est des
pieds c'est son eeepc épisodes des
prochains numéros et alors entre fois on
mettait même un cachet en caoutchouc sur
le bras ah bon parce que c'est la
contremarque et des personnes mais est
ce que est ce que l'européen comprend le
sens de cette pièce où est ce qu'il est
complètement termites iphone aux vôtres
nice il faut être initié n'est ce pas et
on donne au spectateur dayan l'ordonnent
mais cet art japonais une petite notice
sur la pièce où vous la connais par
coeur d'ailleurs alors pendant
l'opération est un peu hein
alors voilà né à saint tite une chose
extraordinaire sur les indicateurs du
chemin de fer
les horaires de départ et d'arrivée sont
en heures minutes et secondes voilà une
précision étonnante on arrive à
15h24 hui seconde absolument admirable
je vous remercie le coeur passeront de
toutes ces précisions et de son savoir
nous retrouverons la semaine prochaine
pour poursuivre ce voyage est rattrapé
ce train quelque part